c'est parti pour le conseil de classe le
maxsym gainey l'un des experts médias de
tpm pays alors aujourd'hui j'ai un très
grand ce copain des scoops parfois un
peu survendu nagui l'animateur phare de
france 2 comme la nouvelle émission
attendait le scoop c'est nagui est un
animateur phare de france 2 c'est quoi
pour vous ça fuse hélicoptère de la
carte au trésor vont pouvoir survoler
les villes
heureusement ça lui arrive de bosser je
sais que l'animateur ali baddou était le
professeur de philo d'emmanuel macron
non mais plus qu'un journaliste média
maxime kenny est un homme aux multiples
talents magicien une balle d'accord
cette balle vous la mettre dans ma mère
d'accord disparition la balle au wat a
marre le bal sont pas c'est quoi ce
biais officiel de bildu midi à la sortie
ou alors mais il a tout vu il a tout vu
et même parfois sniper de l'émission ces
braves un teasing à ses semelles sont
atef star est en croissance
c'est pas dorothée c'est norauto pas de
pitié pour les croissants
oui et oui tout le monde n'a pas autant
de vannes en stock que jean michel tu
m'en fiche un peu
maxime gainey c'est aussi un célibataire
endurci qui pensait avoir trouvé l'amour
en début de saison avec kelly ans aime
énormément au
mais bien sa marque le plus haut mais
leur histoire est vite tombé à l'eau
[Applaudissements]
heureusement il a pu trouver du
réconfort dans les bras de loana si mme
jenny un spécialiste en séduction mais
aussi en expression bien un garde tout
ça laisse une super dernier pour faire
la nouba permettent à boîte à camembert
et voilà pour la saison de maxime
en tout cas une chose est sûre après son
conseil de classe on ira faire la fiesta
[Applaudissements]
il est sympa ouais c'est vrai les gens
d'amis en commun non stop à huy sait qui
est qui
oui s'appelle moore mobisodes est beau
bon et beau s'en prennent au jeu
s'appelle on embrasse moi maître momo on
embrasse moi là il a encore des années
la vache entouré d'amis je l'aide moi je
l'adoré c'est l'excellente c'est
vraiment beau petit protégé de louis
ouest
allez mes chéris les notes pour maxime
gagné les appréciations fait vite et
nous alors y aller on va démarrer avec
gilbert des nos films c'est bien tu es
surpris de votre présence ah c'est vrai
on vous voit moins c'était bien la peine
de liquider thierry moreau pour être
liquidée par christine kelly c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
mais vous avez un point fort c'est que
vous êtes un vrai journaliste médias le
seul cas jamais une info et ça c'est un
vrai tour de magie l'étude or les points
faibles c'est tout le reste les points
faibles c'est que vous n'avez jamais
votre avis et surtout vous êtes déjà
vieux mais maxime vous passez à côté de
votre ville vous passez à côté de kelly
va à côté de tout mais oui lors du la
pécho ouais mais bon on n'a pas cours
qui vous passent et même à côté vous
passez même à côté d'eux bill le
personnage du bigdil étiez génial dont
bill plus en plus de métier loin on
était tranquille
franchement vous avez raté votre vie
mais bon j'ai rarement monde faiblesse
je lave ou cyril motorisés je vous adore
donc il a accepté que je vous sur note
parce que je vous aime bien ces break jo
mais une autre que vous méritez pas du
tout mais je vous adore c'est un
ahurissant 1
[Rires]
oui
quelques arbres à tarbes à aller
médaille il rappela pedeboy maxime
n'écoute pas ce stade affreux jojos
olala c'est pour maxime tu as un bon
élève maxime tu es bosseur turbine pas à
la tâche tu veux toujours bien faire et
pour toi même tu veux en faire un peu
trop
maxime conféreront camarades et c'était
ça c'est vraiment pas négligeable parce
que tu es vraiment un bon camarade mais
c'est vrai que ça allait maxime tu t'es
un peu perdu leur côté effréné et ont
été freinés ben on tend un peu perdus
nous aussi donc évidemment problème de
scoop un petit peu quand même en douane
on doit le dire et puis un problème avec
la paraphrase maxime c'est vrai que
parfois si on te donne la parole en deux
ou trois voitures dit tout ce qui a déjà
été dit mais ça ça mon ami ainsi sa
forte envie de faire des rappels et puis
dernier maxime il faut que tu ose faire
des happenings des choses comme ça parce
que cette planète a un petit peu
rechigner qu'en mer il a bien fait je
voulais vois tu vas plus d'un corner n'a
pas trop voulu jouer le jeu
donc là dessus tucat sera pas ton image
ton image à des bienveillantes tué
sympathique et tué un travailleur les
gens t'aiment donc tu peux t'amuser tout
lâcher aux roses un système qui localise
moi je me rappelle de maxime lorsqu'il
venait me faire des interviews c'est ça
non il a été retrouvé ici je suit les
lycées touchés brandon et les aide pas
du tout pas du tout personne n'essaie de
monsieur ben vas général
la personne touchée bros non non non
mais c'est très bien comme ça
j'ai plein de copains à moi qu'ils
veulent de chez vous la roue tourne la
roue tourne bien sûr qu'il est
célibataire
oui et si j'avais pas vu tu vas à temps
chez bright leurs amis alors sinon je
dirais que oui je te trouve travailleurs
je te trouve bien je retrouve avec
beaucoup d'humour dossier derrière
intelligent cultivé gmi beau gosse
travailleurs beau gosse aussi un accord
entre le chaînon manquant entre le chez
moi pour être ton style 2d liront pas
moi je peux être sa mère donc pas du
tout ça non non il s'arrête la fille
le bahreïn je voulais sortir vous fait
croire alors aidé et puis s'il faut
vraiment trouver peut-être quelque chose
à défaut je trouve que tu prend
peut-être un peu des choses trop à coeur
mais moi je suis comme ça aussi c'est
donc bien cerner les choses trop à coeur
moi aussi oui c'est vrai encouragement à
bercy allez
l état n'est pas jean marc alors oui si
tu étais très gentil tu es très inquiet
que tout le monde
voilà voilà c'est un bon gamin après moi
je te vois faire et c'est vrai que pour
te vois à prendre tes intérêts sans
parker que tu répètes devant kelly
devant agathe devant plus loin devant
des meufs et c'est vrai que c'est ce qui
me gêne le plus c'est une un peu naïve a
laissé trop de paraphrases que la
paraphrase et au bout d'un moment ça
fait que des enfants intervention
généralement ne font que redire ce qui a
été dit quant aux scoops il y en a
jamais donc globalement globalement je
t'aime beaucoup mais cette année je te
mets un brillant 3 aulas alors je lance
ensuite le hashtag mushkin à des métiers
un commentaire hashtag mouche qui
n'adhèrent agathe alors maxime tu es un
élève extrêmement besogneux et attachant
tu viens tu sais moi juste vous vous
habillez votre nom et dont je m'habille
c'est pas mal mais sur la vie de ma mère
on dirait qu'elle a pris les vêtements
tu sais danser qui fera décoller à
garéoult catalogue mais pour les enfants
ça vous va bien ne me quitte pas ça va
vous vous êtes en forme en ce moment
battre est pourquoi je sais dieu bénisse
bon donc je reprends maxime vous êtes un
élément extrêmement besogneux et
attachant du matin au soir vous êtes
disponible pour aider les équipes
préparer l'émission vous arrivez
toujours à l'émission avec une
soixantaine de fiches truffé d'anecdotes
et d'infos alors que sont truffés alors
ça ne se voit pas toujours mais
l'investissement et l'engagement sont
bel et bien là vous êtes un excellent
camarade toujours prêt à aider qu'il se
soit autour de la table toujours là
évidemment et je trouve que vous faites
une excellente saison vous reste une
petite marge de progression pour la
saison prochaine a confirmé
attention à ne pas se perdre on peut
dire au studio parce que c'est vrai ne
passe pas par un personnage parfois un
peu trop forcé parce qu'on sait que tu
es friands de petites équipes de suivre
un peu ringarde et parfois tuent les
forces un peu alors que t'as pas besoin
de ça parce que tu es parfait déjà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maximus maximum c'est du latin c'est
vrai que des fois on part un peu son
latin avec toi parce que on sait pas si
tu es un vrai journaliste qui aiment
plutôt faire l'animateur où c'était un
animateur puis fait journalistes en
attendant grâce par exemple ton
spectacle de magie on s'y perd c'est un
super un tout petit peu sensé pas
exactement où tu es à part ça ça peu
près la seule chose de négatif que je
puisse dire moi je t'aime beaucoup de
thé attachant et bosseur t'es sympa très
bienveillant et donc je te mets le
regarde à l'estomac mais bon allez
commun on s'émeut recettes merci madame
buffet mère alors oui
tu es jeune et photogénique voilà et
malheureusement ici c'est pas la foire
du slip ni génération mannequin la fois
mon petit bonhomme
bon voilà donc tu as un gros point
faible c'est qu'on ne comprend
absolument rien de ce que tu racontes
améliorée et toi en revanche tu t'es
fondre voilà jour après jour on comprend
rien et en revanche c'est pour ça que je
vais peut-être pas être trop sévère avec
toi c'est que du coup peut-être que dans
le plus que tu racontes qu'on comprend
pas il ya peut-être des infos qui se
glisse par ci par là qu'une fois c'est
vrai que j'avais un peu saisis quelques
bribes de phrases fusent et qui auront
encore des bateaux de pêche totale à ça
déboule dans motus donc tu as des as
faim dans tout ça mais voilà mais
franchement c'est la banque ramenez pas
soufflé un peu l'un restant à dire non
non ce que je préfère terminer vite la
voiture c'est méchant
bah vous aimez chantier parce que tu le
mérites
t'es gentil avec tout le monde tu es
adorable tu es toujours là pour les
autres moi tu m'as hyper bien accueilli
on sait tout de suite super bien entendu
nous donna vite formé un duo qui n'était
pas hypocrite
vous rigolez j'ai regardé mais je pose
pour s'est pas arrêté je parle donc pas
à vous d'accord on va attendre vous
travaillé énormément
le problème c'est que ça se ressent pas
énormément achats commence à vous de le
montrer au maximum vous avez le droit
d'être sensible bouffe mais faut pas
spécialement vraiment le montrer à
l'antenne c'est pas nécessaire mais pour
ça je voulais quand même un approche
[Applaudissements]
matthieu allard était cueilli vous
l'avez battu matéo maximoff chaud quand
on m'a demandé de parler de toi j'ai pas
su quoi dire non c'est pas un premier
indice quand même d'après ma montre ta
photo du coup j'ai mis une note ça me
revenus je sais que tu es fan de moi
j'en sors parfaitement moi même plus
jeune j'étais fan de jackson que
dechavanne et et d'autres grands donc
c'est plutôt profité de ce moment pour
te donner des conseils
le premier conseil mon jour c'est lâche
toi une émission de télé un plateau de
télé c'est comme un match de foot il ya
les ronaldo les mais si les je sais pas
quel grand joueur voilà merci zlatan cbc
jean michel c'est moi par exemple
et puis y avait d'autres gars les autres
toi je suis belle mois ouais bah oui mon
cher qu est ce que j aime starbev c'est
une star internationale beaucoup là-bas
le cochon tu vois et donc illégale et
d'autre les besogneux
sauf qu'au moins de talent mais qui sont
là pour mettre justement un évident
racer qui en ont beaucoup à toi c'est ça
ton rôle n'hésite pas être mauvais c'est
ton talent et ça nous mène où en valeur
puisque de toute façon tu donnes tu
pourras pas arriver là mais là où tu es
c'est déjà très bien
la robe assez bon allez une note we not
d'encouragement mon chéri je n'aurais
pas misé à tout le monde
j'ai bien géré mes gars vous dire maxime
way est le seul à l'avoir signée pour
l'année prochaine ouais c'est ça ma
confiance absolue
[Applaudissements]
et ben voilà et cinq chez les
chroniqueurs tu ne peut que monter chez
les collaborateurs à 6,6 et demi je te
le dis à l'évasion
[Applaudissements]